I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark
that's what time
so you guys voted on Twitter to review
crappy video game movies instead of
crappy superhero movies and I'm going to
do that and it worked out perfectly
because Assassin's Creed comes out in
December this couldn't have been more
perfect let's talk about some really
horrible video game adaptations my god
there's a lot to choose from starting
with do a Dead or Alive let's start by
taking a look at the blu-ray the best
movie adaptation of a video game so far
is that a compliment
it's one breathless martial arts action
sequence after the other see that could
also be a positive or negative I'm sure
you all know that the Dead or Alive
games are just the best fighting games
ever made they're way better than the
Mortal Kombat games they're far better
than the Super Smash games
I mean Dead or Alive is the pinnacle of
fighting games we all know that I
remember seeing these games quite often
they went through a period of extreme
popularity as well as the Dead or Alive
volleyball games which for obvious
reasons had some popularity amongst
adolescent boys I won't lie I played a
demo of that game yeah I was hardcore
inevitably we eventually got do a Dead
or Alive the movie a movie with the
acronym DOA really is a bad idea because
this movie in every way is dead on
arrival the opening shot of this movie
has such horrendous CGI it looks like
it's an episode of Beast Wars from the
90s and of course the opening scene
takes place in Japan with a bunch of
Japanese people who speak English all
the time when they're alone so the
character of Kasumi flees her home in a
ripoff of Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
and then this happens
so does she have paragliding equipment
underneath her clothes that entire time
and who sent that device that's some
amazing aim never mind
it honestly is like the filmmakers just
don't want us to question anything that
happens because whenever something
incredibly dumb happens which trust me
is a lot they just cut to like some
beautiful woman in a bikini or some butt
shot it happens a lot trust me we're
going to get into the butt shots we're
gonna we're gonna get into the butt
shots so Jaime Pressly plays Tina
Armstrong and she's introduced with a
hilariously terrible fight scene that
looks like Mortal Kombat annihilation
made love to Dragonball Evolution does
that sound like a good combination to
you because to me that sounds like hell
so Tina gets picked for this tournament
as well as Kristy who gets introduced
with this scene
my god the fact that this even exists is
incredible and her kicks come complete
with whip sound effects we're gonna get
more into those sound effects later
trust me so all of these people have
been chosen for the Dead or Alive
tournament they're supposed to go to
this place where they compete to see
who's the best fighter ever and of
course there's like a stupid dumb
backstory with nanobots because of
course you know nanobots my god there's
a backstory with nanobots this film also
features horrific wirework I guess
Kasumi can fly I mean everyone on this
movie just defies gravity at a constant
rate I don't really know what I was
expecting but at least 90% of this movie
is just pervy shots of girls body so
that's all in it now this this isn't
something that I complain about
necessarily especially in a movie like
this my issue with Dead or Alive the
biggest one that I have with it is that
this film should just be that just girls
fighting and it's like tongue-in-cheek
and fun and that's it this film actually
has the guts to have a story like a
dramatic backstory Kasumi has this
tragic past with her brother who tried
to protect her the horrifyingly bad
villain played by Eric Roberts from The
Dark Knight is somebody who wants to
suck all of these players energy into
him through nano bot technology we'll
get more into that but it's like could
you just had it be a tournament movie
just have it be like the Dragon Ball Z
World Tournament my god what were they
thinking so I said I'd mentioned more of
the sound effects this girls kick sounds
like a rocket flew by
and this guy's arms come complete with
Goldeneye 64 sound effects also what's
hilarious is these people don't meet at
a tournament arena they just have like
watches that flash the person's name
they're going to fight and that person
just like shows up in their hotel room
like bust through the door destroys the
property they have fights like
everywhere in public in front of people
they don't have a dedicated arena
couldn't they have just had an arena
anything just anything they just they
just show up and be like hey we're
supposed to fight oh shit ah and of
course what would any movie like this be
without a ton of lesbian jokes oh my god
no dad she's just another fighter we're
just sleeping together I'd see that no
no I mean what we're not sleeping
together we're just sleeping sweetie
I've come at a bad time again Anna does
a Kristy know about you too dad yep
that's what this movie needed lesbian
jokes but hey at least there's a
volleyball scene it's probably the best
scene in the movie cuz it's so dumb and
you just like fine there's also another
backstory with this girl named a yani
who's stalking Kasumi everywhere because
she's in love with kasumi's brother or
something and she constantly challenges
Kasumi to fights so in between the
horribly choreographed tournament fight
scenes that don't actually take place in
a tournament arena we get a bunch of
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon ripoff
scenes this film was directed by Corey
Yuwen mmm this was the last film he ever
directed and that really doesn't
surprise me at all now I'm going to show
you an actual scene from this movie I
have changed nothing
so the beginning of the next fight scene
is like the beginning of a terrible porn
I have never seen a more fanservice e
movie than this this is the closest I've
ever seen to like an anime fan service
live-action movie but this fight scene
did give me my biggest laugh in the
entire film
so when Tina has to do her big fight
scene for whatever reason she chooses
denim and boots you know the best
fighting attire and she's also given an
amazingly lifelike and realistic sound
effect so right here this very abrupt
and unnecessary backstory is revealed
with the dude running this joint this
nanobots scheme he has and it's just
like why this should have been just a
fight movie a mindlessly dumped popcorn
film and we're given this huge backstory
and characters have dramatic depth but
hey I mean at least we get this moment
out of the scene and now we get a sword
fight scene where this girl is
apparently slicing through dozens of
people and there is not a drop of blood
in sight this is pathetic I'm sorry how
am I supposed to believe that any of
this is taking place how am I supposed
to believe in ounce of this this girl is
slicing through like 35 people and
they're all just like ahhh and this is
where the movie truly goes to shit I
mean it was already awful but this this
is when it gets bad Donavan captures
everyone and then uses special
sunglasses that he refers to as the
future to absorb all of their various
powers and abilities I'm actually not
sure what happens but he puts on
sunglasses and then can analyze what
someone is about to do and he do comes
like the best fighter ever as long as
he's wearing those sunglasses kasumi's
brothers of course still alive he's been
kept there as a slave or something I
don't know it's amazing
bleah bad the next moment and the movie
is by far the most
unbelievable one out loud when I watched
this last night I said to myself how was
this released in theaters so of course
all the girls have to team up to fight
this guy and just like every other fight
scene in the movie it's filled with
obvious stunt doubles terrible wirework
and very basic fight choreography more
falling people are saved hilariously and
then the dudes sunglasses finally fall
off and now he can't fight anymore I
just have one question if you're like
this evil mastermind and you want to
become a super strong fighter why would
you make the one object that makes you a
super-strong fighters
sunglasses possibly the worst thing to
wear during a fight scene forget about
the Matrix Reloaded and the Matrix
Revolutions wearing sunglasses well
fighting is probably a terrible idea
because you're just gonna fly off why
would you make that be your only hope so
of course the entire place is eventually
going to blow up because there's a
ticking time bomb the guy said for some
reason who knows why you wanted to blow
up this place but everyone jumps away
and it's slow-motion explosions and this
film has no idea where to end by the way
everyone's making out on a boat and then
it kind of cuts to black like hey it's
over and then we get a weird montage of
all of the sexy parts and they're like
hey I guess that ending wasn't cool
enough so let's show a montage of the
sexy parts and let people leave on a
high but then it continues to go the
girls are like back in Japan and they're
gonna fight all these men and I guess
they're a team now so yay they didn't
make any more of these thank God guys do
a Dead or Alive is terrible whatever
with everything about this movie is bad
it's awful I mean what did you expect me
to say guys stay tuned so I'm going to
be reviewing some more terrible video
game movies leading up to Assassin's
Creed you guys are the best thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
you